je suis le père Yves Frot
j'ai 67 ans
curé de Beaune pour la 9e année
prêtre c'est mon métier
j'étais en CM1 quand mes venus l'idée de
devenir prêtre mes parents étaient très
chrétiens et puis le curé de l'époque
était pas mal ce qui me touche une
motive dans mon sacerdoce c'est le fait
de rencontrer les personnes de les aider
à faire un pas supplémentaire dans la
foi de les soutenir quand il y a de la
difficulté
[Musique]
ma journée commence
par le moment le plus difficile pour moi
c'est de nous le dire
partir de ce moment-là il y a la prière
du matin célébrer la messe quand c'est
mon tour et la messe est à 9h
j'aime bien les salutations dans les
lettres de saint Paul pourquoi parce que
on s'aperçoit que Paul ne travaille
jamais seul la messe essentiellement un
temps de prière et de remerciement à
Dieu donc c'est à la fois faire se
rassemblée du monde aider à la prière un
certain nombre de personnes et célébrer
le caresser en redisant les paroles de
Jésus notre Père qui est aussi que ton
nom soit sanctifié la main c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est le sommet de
la vie chrétienne c'est tout ça et donc
il faut quand même la célébrer dignement
je dis pas que j'ai pas d'émotion mais
il faut quand même garder une distance
parce que je crois que si on est en
plein dans l'affectif et dans les motifs
c'est pas génial non plus
[Musique]
je viens tous les matins parce que ça me
donne le peps pour la journée
du père-froid
très dynamique moi j'aime ça franchise
il y a une certaine tendresse aussi à la
fois derrière son aspect un peu brut
en 2021 on a célébré 105 W 40 mariages
et 212 obsèques ça peut être des grosses
journées ça peut se terminer à 23 heures
parce qu'on a des réunions à 20h30
samedi et dimanche matin on n'est pas en
famille
on a quelques confrères qu'on fait un
burn-out ça c'est clair mais il faut de
temps en temps recharger les batteries
alors moi je l'avais pris et en
définitive on a eu un appel des pompes
funèbres pour nous dire que comme tu
connaissais c'est toi qui célébrait
ça pose tu sais qui est la sacristine et
donc là maintenant on va aller au
secrétariat qui nous est parfaitement
utile parce que il y a tout plein de
gens qui passent
bonjour Isabelle
rétaire c'est la secrétaire qui fait
tout organisation
le prêtre il est là pour recevoir les
gens de je dirais du point de vue moral
la vocation prête c'est le service il y
a trop de gens qui mettent le prêtre sur
un piédestal il faut pas le toucher et
surtout ils veulent qu'il soit parfait
et comme tout le monde voilà
nous sommes ici à l'intérieur de
l'ancien caramel de Beaune il se passe
ce qu'il y a dans tous les sanctuaires
c'est-à-dire une vie de prière
mon rôle c'est vers le lien entre la
paroisse et la communauté des
religieuses
si je recommence ma vie je fais
exactement la même chose je vois pas ce
que je pourrais faire d'autre cette vie
ne compte spirituellement humainement et
psychologiquement j'en suis heureux
c'est aussi simple que ça
[Musique]